same booty booty booty booty walking
everywhere booty booty booty booty
rockin everywhere what's up guys i'm
shanley I am out of bluffco today we are
here in Vegas for Bleacher Report's for
the 2018 Summerlee and we are at the
exclusive sneaker spot 12 a.m. run
we got a Los Angeles Lakers cow Kuzma
and Josh are with us and today we are at
their mercy as we work the floor of the
store yep we have earpieces we have
hidden cameras and whatever they say we
have to do let go I am terrified let's
go
good luck Shaq it's a nice shirt man
can I have a hug man come on you a good
guy you a good guy I always need people
with Black Sabbath jerk and good people
I appreciate you man you go over there
just do 15 dope in Jack one two three
four five hey man ten eleven twelve
thirteen fourteen fifteen you know
sometimes you gotta work out he's gotta
work out sometimes you gotta feel good I
feel great my blood is flowing clueless
and you use coos as a slang word you
know these these right here these are
like the coos you know I'm Sam the COO
these are the coos that's what the kid
that's that's what they say now instead
of cool they say this is the clues start
doing the shoot dance whenever I see him
I'm like don't I keep doing it keep
doing it sure sure sure
you're gonna buy my work cuz I'm getting
tired shushu yeah yeah yeah made a cool
like cool Zoomer yeah like how cool
Timur tell me you think our Kuzon was
overrated but also Calculon is overrated
really yeah
gosh I go if you need to fall down fall
down fall down you know you look good
hold on oh don't watch that crack glass
out for that crack it'll get you okay
you guys need any help like just looking
how was that drink I am jealous of you
but I asked for said ass gonna try that
cuz I like I'm like a margarita expert I
can't get a cent as you horse try to
smell her hair what do you use Herbal
Essences Pantene Pro Z this is just
sitting there little fella
head and shoulders Aziz soap and water
policy is it really make I have a sip of
yours yeah thanks why is it great go
just chug it just chug it no just chug
it down it down it so good
[Laughter]
that was amazing thanks bro appreciate
you a group hug group hug
alright I honestly I don't know what it
is but your energy feels good now is
wonder if I can get like a group hug
just like shared emotion like this is a
great day it's Saturday you shared your
drink
I've been shopping having a lot come on
come over here please
are you cool if I just hug you though go
ahead I appreciate you man oh [ __ ] when
you see them EXO exhibits height
exaggerated oh Lord in my heart as hell
what are those sketches you crazy you
crazy are you going okay let me see them
let me see them let me see them
oh whatever let me see go up and talk to
those people they just walked in as ja
Rule holla holla what's up hey how you
livin the whole conversation all my
babies is ready to get shoes shirts hats
jerseys girls saying booty booty booty
booty rockin everywhere booty booty
booty booty rockin everywhere
young get me kill man so go up to the do
decide the world
what was it world's okay sadly yeah and
challenging push-up competition hey man
I see your shirt I see it says world's
okay athlete okay I think I think that's
me Joe I think I'm the world's most okay
athlete let's have a push-up challenge
now you don't want to do that I just I
just did 10 early I'm ready to go oh
thank you a t-shirt
he's bet merchandise here we go oh my
god it's gone man Wow hey say that you
had when he does push-ups a he has bad
form one two three what is that hey Chad
what was that
Chad go to shake his hand say good job
to run out the store way late good job
brother
good job brother around the store
all right we need to mail more now I'm
not much with mail guy my god hey man
this is some boy gonna make some money
in the house this is the worst day of my
life
we're gonna go oh god I'm about to walk
all right well not so walk for shame
there we go walk over towards him what's
a good player what's gonna play good man
it's telling you this mother may oh all
day I've been smelling mayonnaise all
day what it is
Giulio go grab his bread and get the
mayonnaise off of his face and just wipe
it off yeah yeah yeah go back to the guy
go back to the got make sure
everything's good you get a man anything
in particular you looking for oh I've
been looking for that my man thank you
oh my god let me know you need anything
you let me know
laughter you missed a spot oh I got a
little bit left hold up oh yeah what's
up you got mayonnaise and I've they ran
out oh yes that's a friend
you want some that's a friend your good
friend right there you wish you had a
friend like that a man before you go we
got to tell you something
y'all never heard of a bleacher before
you got that right app on your phone
we've had cameras all over here and
we're we're bleacher report and there's
two Lakers that are telling me what to
say to you guys what Kyle Kuzma yo
what's up Mike if we devote like
different were yeah
yo don't act like you know Johnson
salad the bleach report we have served
be able to come out here have a great
summer